c'est la première tablette que vient
sortir oneplus c'est le oneplus pad on a
ici un grand écran de 11,61 pouces vous
avez un taux de rafraîchissement de 144
Hz ça s'adresse surtout au gamer qui
vole une très grosse nudité lors de
leurs différentes session gaming à
savoir qu'ici ce n'est pas du tout une
tablette qui a de la 5G on se parle bien
évidemment ici d'une dalle LCD c'est pas
du OLED sous le capot on vient de
trouver un médiathèque d'immens City
9000 on a 8 Go de RAM c'est des R5 et
128 Go de stockage en ufs 3.0 une très
grosse batterie de 9510 milliampères
heure combien charger en super vous 67
watts sans oublier deux caméras à
l'arrière un grand angle 13 mégapixels
et un ultra grand angle de 8 mégapixels
du haut ici du Bluetooth 5.3 bref une
fiche technique musclée pour la première
tablette de oneplus et en plus ce qui
est intéressant ce que nous montre
oneplus ici aujourd'hui MWC c'est un
écosystème qui se dessine davantage avec
des écouteurs avec un smartphone un
moniteur également donc on voit que
oneplus est top sa gamme avec cette
tablette qui vient la compléter ici en
France est-ce que vous d'ailleurs vous
avez un smartphone oneplus est-ce que
vous en avez déjà eu un est-ce que ça
pourrait vous intéresser est-ce que
cette tablette oneplus l'écosystème ça
vous botte marqué moi ça bien évidemment
dans les commentaires